hey everybody you're watching gamespot
com and we just watched the square enix
III press conference we've got a lot to
unpack I'm Alexa ray and I'm joined by
some of my favorite gentlemen dan and
two more and Kevin oh thank you i love
you guys and we are going to talk about
some really freaking awesome games first
up I want to hit it right away de deus
ex this is the first time we've seen any
any in-game capture any Indian gameplay
what did you think today is X mankind
divided I think it looked really good
the environments were really kind of
full of detail and they're getting
closer and closer to the environments
that they have in their cg trailers
which obviously look really really great
but when you get into the game itself
say with like human Revolution it was it
was a bit of a disconnect there yeah I
like where the story is going like the
the 78 people are now the outlawed and
they're on the run which gives me a good
chance to basically be I'm Jensen and
stab fools a lot and um which is kind of
like the the angle they went for in this
trailer it's not surprising considering
its e3 so they want big booms and bangs
and that kind of stuff but I don't know
about you guys but I play more stealth
so it was kind of like disappointing to
see I mean the game looks amazing but
just point to see like my playing style
not kind of highlight it was difficult
to tell how the game actually plays
because it cuts so quickly and
everything sort of exploding lots of
watermelons flying there seem to be
heaps more valuable objects that we just
getting you know smashed in combat as
well yeah they're certainly not going
subtle are they I mean it even beyond
that you see like welcome to hell
scrawled there and you see in the
presentation a comparison to apartheid
which I don't know that is necessarily a
comfortable you know allegory in this
case and and and you know all the black
and all the gold and I'm kind of
wondering maybe we can maybe we can tone
this down a little bit yeah making this
look like just a big bang boom kind of
well they're also not going subtle on
the story front as well because you now
start out as a double agent and you know
the conspiracy is right there from the
get-go know that sample days x kind of
plot in a bit yawning the Illuminati oh
oh yeah but the Illuminati yeah mommy's
what about these new augmentations like
what if you what do you think of what
we've seen him wielding so far what's
interesting is the smart vision the
ability to save your walls now sort of
highlights their weapon and their
inventory item as well so it gives you
be more information about that I like
that as someone I mean they only like I
said the only show to action here but
it's one of the kind of like the best
parts of playing stuff is knowing what's
in your surroundings and figuring that
stuff out and as games are kind of
advancing having like that kind of
information pop up in the UI it's really
satisfying for someone who likes to do
like no kill and no alert run throughs
and that kind of thing so I'm excited
about that element of it about you Kevin
you excited I am I keep thinking about
the other side of things like okay so
let's say I don't want to be still like
sometimes I like to be in a set you know
an assassin more than more than that
stealth dude so I'm wondering you know
instead of having just those because for
example in the last game we had just
those spots where you could punch in and
there might be stuffed in there to
collect or whatever now I'm wondering
could I can I just punch through walls
is it going to be destructible enough
that if I see you know a silhouette on
the other side of the wall I'd love to
be able to just punch through and grab
him I don't think it will be but that
would would be nice it was ok yeah I
wonder if they have a giant like what
was it refrigerator that you could get
me around yeah basically indestructible
for ya you don't even need that anymore
because you've got this new armored skin
that yeah we see that there's like the
black / / call kind of thing yeah she
appears that looks really cool the
animation that looks awesome yeah the
power to turn into deus ex concept
exactly let's examine we won't be seeing
that game until early 2016 kind of a
bummer but keep working on it that's
deus ex let us know what you think of
what you saw today in the comments
you